all right so tell me about the music
video are those real cockroaches cuz I'm
from Texas
I don't do clock right I hate
cockroaches yeah me tell me those aren't
real what
no those are okay look look look oh my
god okay so one this was not my idea it
was on my brother Cole Bennett wouldn't
go in your mouth no it did okay
but it went elsewhere that I don't want
to say on TV that's crazy but um I feel
violated just hearing it okay all right
so someone hate you no this is actually
like my homie who shot this video I
shall call Bennett so he sent the
treatment and you know he had the
roaches on the treatment but I'm just
assuming a CGI so by the time I get
there oh and he's like yo you got to put
these roaches on him like absolutely not
like I'm not doing this but I mean yeah
but he knows I'm always like you know
how somebody hits you with your own sins
I'm always like mind over matter and you
know anything further art so he's like
bro what happened to mind over matter
the song but I'm like you know the song
is about like three minutes and thirty
seconds and I had to like wrap that with
the roaches on me like five different
times that's like 15 minutes worth of
roaches
no yeah you know what I would have been
I would have gone back to serving
roaches in the house sometime growing up
just to come back I had to do it and put
them all over me to reach into the
popcorn bag and a damn roaches in here
grow up in a the bricks I grew up in the
sticks oh yeah it was not good are you
manifesting some Grammys oh absolutely I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this